Okay.
No,
that's going to be assume like,
it's so scary because you think if
you'd like to that pit of unhappiness,
like the lowest get your defaults
and happiness, but when I let go,
I realize like it wasn't happiness,
it was happiness and this. I was like,
Holy Shit.
You know,
it's like we're literally all hanging
onto the side of a cliff and you know
someone's billows like, let go. I'll
catch you. You're like, no, if I let go,
I'll die.
And then you actually do let go.
But he requires so much to
just like go cause again,
you've been hanging on
your entire fucking life.
Everything you've been doing
has been reinforcing it.
Assumption upon assumption upon
assumption, belief, belief. It's like,
hang on or I will die. And you think that
the journey is just to keep hanging on.
It's like let go.
Easier said than done.
It's easy to do but hard to do.
You make that false assumption
that our default is unhappy. Wrong.
Okay.
That false assumption is the cause of
every bad thing in your life and a that's
huge. Consciously, it's not as hard
to let go. While your problems,
it's not as hard to let go of that wrong
assumption because you're conscious of
it.
The hard part is this assumption is
buried deep down in your subconscious and
that's the tough part.
It's sitting down and diving into it
and this is the shit that's fucking
terrifying.
This is the shit that's the scariest thing
you'll do in your entire fucking life.
It's sitting down and diving into it.
Bad Memories.
Do you want to be aware
of different bad memories?
Do you want to be aware of every
fucking rejection you experienced
Carol?
Stuffing in your subconscious?
Do you want to be aware of different
emotions? You're angry, you feel guilty.
You shoved that in your subconscious.
Different emotional traumas
as you're growing up.
Shove that in your subconscious. We're
just shoving all this shit and stuff.
It's like the trash bin of
her fucking mind. I was like,
just throw it in the trash. Never focused
on like never be aware of it again,
but just cause we shoved it there.
Just cause we're not focusing on
it doesn't mean it goes anywhere.
It's still there. You're just not
aware of, you know, Eckhart toll calls,
this pain body attack for example,
something happens and you get extremely
mad more than you logically slash
consciously think you
shouldn't be mad about right.
That's when Shit that you've been
stuffed down kind of pops out.
It kind of takes over, but it's not just
anger because we think, oh pain body,
it's anything that's painful.
What's another one? [inaudible]
logically we know it doesn't fucking
make sense to be that scared something
takes over.
Fear of rejection.
Is that like a logical like
from a conscious perspective
like is it make sense
to me that fucking scared?
No,
that is a pain body attack and that's
like the process is like sitting down and
being like, what have I store down there?
Again, it's not running away from it.
It's like stopping facing it and like
bringing that shit up and experiencing it
and that's why it's like so fucking
hard and that sort of so stubborn.
It's like we just don't want to just
fucking keep putting it off no matter what
it takes. Thinking that maybe someday
it'll just magically click them all.
Just be happy. New. Okay. You
cannot run away from the pain.
You got to run through it.
Focus. Next time you have
that little pain, body attack,
next time something's triggered.
Maybe someone says something that upsets
you more than it should instead of what
do we all do?
As I said before,
we tried to escape it instead of running
away from it. Go into that. Like again,
you break up with your girlfriend.
There's another one,
like all this trauma kicks in.
Don't go for the fucking drink.
Don't go for the drugs. Don't go for
the party. Don't go for the movie.
Don't go for the video game. Don't go
for the food. Don't try to escape it.
Go into that shit. That's
the way there. And uh, again,
you're fighting experience resistance.
She'll probably have to go
into the resistance first on.
You're probably gonna be scared shitless
to cause you think if you let a little
bit of it out, everything will
fucking come out. And that is true.
Everything will come out like you'll,
you'll be in fuck tears.
It'll just be absolute hell.
That will happen.
But that's the only way to
actually process it because
you're just hanging on it.
And until you let go of that shit, it's
always going to block you from getting,
finding that default that is happens.
Bring awareness to it.
Don't run away from it.
Let it come up. And again,
this is hard because our conditioning
to society keeps telling you,
run away from pain,
went away from pain towards pleasure
to hear it go towards the pain,
let it come up. Um, embody it fully.
Let go of the resistance around it. And
then of course, actually experience it.